a man accused of starting a Southern
California wildfire that threatens
thousands of homes is set to appear in
court later today the so-called holy
fire has burned more than 6,000 acres
and destroyed 12 buildings it is one of
18 large fires raging in California
right now Jonathan Vigliotti is near the
fire lines in Lake Elsinore Jonathan
good morning to you and good morning to
you the holy fire stands at about five
percent contained this morning and you
can see some of the flames some as tall
as trees this blaze began in a National
Forest but has since grown dangerously
close to homes and I want to show you
one of the first lines of defense this
pink residue it's actually fire
retardant dropped overnight from planes
as firefighters work to protect this
neighborhood massive flames shot up the
ridge line as the holy fire pushed
closer to densely populated hillside
neighborhoods families watch the fire
inch down the hill as officials ordered
homeowners to get out immediately we're
gonna hang out here as long as we can
and then see what happens but you know
if it gets super super bad then we'll
leave dc-10 swooped in close to the
ground dropping flame retardant on homes
under mandatory evacuation orders we
continue to bring assets
throughout the state of California and
across the nation authorities arrested
this man late Tuesday 51 year old
Forrest Clark
they say that physical evidence and
witness statements connected him to the
fire which burned several cabins near
the one where he lived
Clark reportedly had conflicts with his
neighbors and sent an email to a local
fire chief last week warning quote this
place will burn this is a monster who
would go out with low humidity and high
wind and the highest heat temperatures
this time of the year and intentionally
set the forest on fire further north the
record-breaking Mendocino complex fire
has now burned more than 470 square
miles and is still threatening more than
nine thousand structures meteorologists
who help predict the fires behavior say
weather conditions have helped fuel the
more than a dozen fires burning across
the state we're dealing with that six
years of below normal rainfall a drought
isn't going to make this
a bad fire season for the drought is
gonna make a bad fire season worse and
smoke from these wildfires have
blanketed about one-third of the state
where we stand right now you can
certainly smell all this smoke and hear
the crackling of this blaze earlier this
morning as we were driving in when it
was still dark some of these ridges look
like volcanoes erupting now there is
some good news this morning that
temperature is expected to drop we've
been feeling that this morning the
humidity is expected to rise all of that
expected to help firefighters as they
continue to battle this blaze they could
use some good news those firefighters
working around the clock Jonathan thank
you